[Applause]
[Music]
today's video is going to answer a
question you've all been wondering at
some time or another what's the point of
watching visualpolitik how does it
affect me to know what's happening with
oil in some country when i don't even
know where that country even is well
today's video illustrates that what we
tell you on this channel affects you
more than you might think no matter
which country you're watching this video
from just take a look at this month's
electricity and gas bill to know what
we're talking about and you are not the
only ones with the problem we are
talking about something truly worrying
scottish power warns of energy market
massacre
amid soaring prices millions in europe
could struggle to heat their homes so no
you're not the only one who has a
problem it's happening all over europe
but it's also spreading all over the
planet prices are skyrocketing in asia
and in the usa and skyrocketing energy
prices are a problem for post-pandemic
economic recovery when these things
happen many blame the government
everyone blames their own country's
government but the truth is that we are
facing a global crisis we are looking at
the first big crisis of the energy
transition so the question is why has
the price of energy skyrocketed how long
is this situation going to last and more
importantly where could the way out of
this crisis lie today on visualpolitik
we're going to answer these questions
but first let's take a look at a bit of
history
[Music]
the years of plenty
our story today is going to be a fairly
straightforward one of course there are
political aspects this is pure and
simple economics the law of supply and
demand the oil crisis of 1973 the most
famous one occurred because the price of
crude oil multiplied by four after the
arab countries decided to reduce their
production of dinosaur juice less supply
same demand higher price we can also
look at what happened in 2011 the price
of oil peaked in real terms thanks to
the runaway demand from emerging china
higher demand same supply higher price
this was the trend until the fracking
revolution came along
oil prices in constant currency
increased between 1971 and 2011 by
almost 900 to give you an idea other
basic commodities only increased by 68
over the same period with the oil price
settled above 100 a barrel the
conditions were in place that made it
profitable to exploit oil and gas fields
through fracking this technique was a
real revolution in the world's energy
markets suddenly there was much more
supply of oil as a result the price of
oil plummeted by almost half in 2014.
at the time the energy sector was
experiencing the years of plenty the
fracking revolution reduced the price of
oil at a time when the world was
starting to take the green economy
seriously at the end of 2015 the paris
agreement the cornerstone of the fight
against climate change was being
negotiated renewables such as wind and
solar were beginning to prove
competitive with other fuels such as
coal and natural gas the forecast for
the future could not be better
coal and gas to stay cheap but
renewables still win race on costs
in its 2016 report bloomberg new energy
finance cut its long-term forecasts for
coal and gas prices by about a third it
believed that prices would fall in the
face of expected oversupply for both
fuels and of course this forecast also
implied in reduced electricity prices
since gas and coal are typically used
when nuclear hydro and renewables are
not sufficient to meet electricity
demand
[Music]
everything was going smoothly we were
spending on energy hand over fist but
the fact is that since the paris
agreement was approved there has been a
movement to stop investing in fossil
fuels institutional investors were the
first and many private investors too in
fact we've seen news events that we
never thought would have happened
heirs to rockefeller oil fortune divest
from fossil fuels over climate change in
the last five years there has been no
talk in the industry about anything
other than the energy transition we
accept that solving the problem of
global warming is one of the most
important challenges ahead of us the
planet can no longer absorb any more
greenhouse gas emissions and one of two
things needs to happen either we stop
polluting by 2050 or the planet's going
to be hotter than neymar's birthday
parties it is true that carbon capture
and storage technologies are being
researched but however much carbon is
stored we still need to pollute less or
as they say lately decarbonize the
economy
and this transition is generating
intense pressure on oil companies
especially european ones to move away
from fossil fuels the data speaks for
itself in 2014 more than 800 billion was
invested in exploration of new deposits
of dinosaur juice now that investment
has fallen to less than half listen up
global upstream investments set for a
15-year low falling from 383 billion in
2020.
[Music]
there is the case of the oil company
royal dutch shell in 2014 with crude oil
prices above 100 a barrel they invested
more than 30 billion dollars into
upstream projects that is in exploration
projects for new oil fields today they
are investing less than eight billion
dollars in addition they have sold
almost all of their fracking operations
in texas and they are thinking of
winding down all the fields they have in
nigeria of which they have many
and i know what a lot of you are
thinking this is all great news for the
planet big business wants less and less
fossil fuels the problem that in this
life everything has a price so does the
green transition we're going to have a
look at that right now
[Music]
the cobra effect
[Applause]
when you try to solve a problem and
actually make it worse you are the
latest victim of the cobra effect it's
so cool because in the days of the
british empire there were a lot of
poisonous cobras in india so the british
offered a bounty for every dead cobra
and now i know what you were thinking
they surely killed them all it was a
classic textbook win-win you bring a
dead cobra and you get the money the
problem was that the smartest people in
the place were breeding cobras and then
killing them as soon as the british
realized that despite dropping rupees
the problem was persisting they stopped
giving rewards so the cobra farmers let
the cobras go free making the initial
problem worse suddenly there were more
cobras than ever in other words the road
to hell is paved with good intentions
here on visualpolitik we have never had
problems with green energy but we do
believe that the problem may come with
the pace at which they want to develop
the energy transition
investment in clean energy must triple
by 2030 to curb climate change
two-thirds of the investment in the
energy sector is already invested in
renewables but as you can see a lot more
investment is needed if we are to
succeed in tackling climate change which
is why we say be very careful with the
pace because some energy sources must be
replaced by others and all within a good
plan why do we insist on this well
because at the end of the day when there
are difficulties the problem is not
going to be with the government in power
or the businessman the problem is going
to be with you
germany flirts with power crunch and
nuclear and coal exit we said it at the
beginning scarcity is synonymous with
rising prices so well let's go ahead
with the energy transition the problem
with renewables is that they depend on
weather conditions you can't use them
whenever you want without wind the wind
turbine doesn't move and without sun the
photovoltaic panels delivers less than
coman when he was coaching barcelona so
we need base load energy power plants
that we know will not fail us and that
will be available when we need them
[Music]
we could do what we did in the 19th
century and burn coal but we didn't like
it because it pollutes too much so out
with that let's get rid of the thermal
power stations the fact is that if it is
a question of not emitting co2 we could
use nuclear energy but wait we also
think it's wrong to split uranium atoms
in case the plant explodes so scrap that
let's remove the nuclear plants what's
left then well we could burn natural gas
it is still a fossil fuel but burning
gas emits less co2 in coal or fuel oil
so what's the problem well for one thing
it turns out that the countries from
which we buy gas are not very
trustworthy and then there is the fact
that as we no longer invest in oil we
find that there is less and less natural
gas available
the fossil fuel industry needs constant
reinvestment to avoid depleting its
reserves the problem is that the fall in
investment in the oil sector has a
spillover effect on natural gas its
reserves are expected to shrink at a
faster rate as a large part of the gas
fields are discovered while drilling for
crude oil
until now however we have not been
alarmed as gas prices were more or less
contained we thought that it was all
plain sailing and on top of that if we
already had that false sense of security
the pandemic came to accommodate us even
more with a dramatic drop in demand we
even reached a point where gas was
already being given away for free even
with the newspaper
2020 average henry hub natural gas price
hits lowest level in 25 years sure when
there is plenty there are fewer problems
but hold on a minute because another
thing we weren't aware of is that the
shortage of lng terminals is a major
bottleneck for the global natural gas
market
[Music]
lng is the only option for shipping gas
from places where it's plentiful like
the united states australia or qatar to
places where it's scarce like europe and
asia but building terminals takes time
so it's not a short-term solution and so
we have found that everything that made
natural gas cheaper when the pandemic
broke out has now become more expensive
in a massive swing of the pendulum
the perfect storm
[Music]
it looks like the worst of the pandemic
is over and of course after the massive
confinements we experienced in 2020 the
economy has returned to growth this has
led to direct consequences on the energy
sector because the world is back to
demanding oil it has demanded coal again
above all it has demanded gas again
so of course we have a tremendous demand
for gas at a time when supply is less
abundant than before because investment
in fossil fuels has come to a standstill
and what happens in the market when
these conditions are met well at this
point i'm sure i don't need to tell you
gas prices skyrocket as the global
energy crisis worsens in this situation
many have turned their attention to
russia the european union directly
accused kremlin of not offering enough
gas for european markets some speculated
that russia was encouraging gas
shortages as a pressure measure to
finally get nordstream 2 its new gas
pipeline with germany up and running
however nothing could be further from
the truth
last winter was very cold and just as
the european deposits are emptier than
usual at this time of the year the
russians also needed to replenish their
own deposits in fact the good news is
that they seem to be in a position to
offer more gas to europe
natural gas prices fall on putin order
for more russian exports however
visualpolitik viewers the bad news for
the european union is piling up in the
face of the energy transition dependence
on russian gas is still rampant
approximately one-third of the gas
consumed in europe comes from the east
so once again it is showing how
vulnerable brussels berlin and other
major european capitals are the
kremlin's goodwill added to that is how
vulnerable the european union is
becoming to the weather we have already
seen the consequences that a harsh
winter has had on prices but then the
summer was lethal too
[Music]
energy prices in europe hit records
after wind stops blowing during the
summer europe's wind power production
was reduced by almost half and of course
if there is no wind the problem starts
it was a perfect storm with more demand
and no wind there was no choice but to
burn natural gas to meet the electricity
demand
the worst thing is that there is no
guarantee that this scenario will not
happen again so we can ask ourselves
what solutions there are the first way
to avoid gas shortages is obvious the
fields are there so more gas can always
be produced the problem is that it is a
solution that requires a certain amount
of investment and it would take a few
years to produce results another option
is to expand the energy mix to have
other alternatives how well i could tell
you but it would be better if bill gates
explained it to you we expect
reliability
from the electric grid and that we're
going to have more strange weather
conditions and so really looking at
those to understand is that nuclear is
at storage how do we maintain
reliability the other alternative is the
simplest accept the energy transition
with its virtues and its defects that
means grinning and bearing the situation
while digging deep in our pockets to pay
for more energy the problem is that this
will not only affect your bills but
industries will also pay more for energy
and they will charge you by raising the
price of their products in other words
there'll be a complete loss of
competitiveness
of course europe cannot afford this
option because it would mean continuing
to lose ground and expanding gas
production is not easy as the world's
main gas fields are located beyond the
continent so debates that seems to have
been overcome are being reopened take a
look
researcher brussels is paving the way
for nuclear power's green revival the
fundamental issue is that nuclear power
does not emit greenhouse gases so this
first crisis of the energy transition
has taught us that nuclear energy is
still an option to be considered firstly
because no one is willing to pay more
for energy secondly because renewables
are still not enough to cover all demand
and baseload energy is still needed one
example is spain which needs to import
electricity from france whose mix is
mainly nuclear and morocco which burns
coal
[Music]
and finally because while we may insist
on renouncing nuclear keep in mind that
this gas price crisis has pushed many
countries to turn their thermal power
plants back on so as i said before
either the energy transition is well
planned or we may be forced to take a
step backwards in the fight against
global warming but now the question is
over to you would you give nuclear a
fresh chance or would you gamble
everything on the development of
renewables you could leave me answer in
the comments and of course don't forget
that we have new videos every week so
subscribe to the channel so you don't
miss any of our updates and if you like
this video like it and we'll see you in
the next one take care see you soon
[Music]